welcome back to pga chain design today
we are going to talk about how to make
this hexagon eternity ring and have all
in line align perfectly are you ready
let's get started
[Music]
before we start the demonstration you
can download this storm there's a link
at the description below sign up the
newsletter and you can download the
stone to follow along once you download
a stone then you can open that file and
just using the copy and the past into
this file when you bring in your file if
the stone is not right in the center of
your construction plan all you need to
do is come into the align tool
and we want to use the command align
centers and at my top view just type it
0 hit enter then you will have this
piece there right in the center you can
scale up and down by holding the gumball
with the scale tool to make it big or
small
once you have it you can move it to
whatever height that you want it i'm
using the circle command
and type it zero in my front view and
i'd like to use my demonstration for
diameter 16 millimeter and you hit enter
then you have something like that okay
now to make a hexagon setting we're
gonna coming into the command for
polygon and right here that you can type
it how many sides you want since we want
to have a hexagon i'm going to snapping
into the zero and stay with six there
now you can decide how big your setting
is going to be so we'll have this curve
if you have this curve we're going to
move it to the top for whatever the
stone is going to sit
basically
you can extrude this one straight right
and then we can trim it later for
whatever is extra but it coming with the
one problem that i find let me show you
what that problem is
we have this setting right here and i
simply just going to use the command
polar array and i'm gonna snapping into
the zero
basically
kind of guessing
for 18 of them 360 degree
so this is what we get as you notice
that there's a gap there and we want
them to be as close as possible right so
let me try 19 over there
and when you try knighting the steel gap
then i want to try 20 over there still
gap try 21. so it kind of moving in
this look really good but still you're
going to see this part there so let me
go ahead and record a history and then
hit enter now if you're looking at the
render view this is not too bad but it's
not too good either because you can see
that you have these things that your
children need to remove it right so my
goal is have them like me hundred
percent there all right and then also if
you take a look on the render view and
you will see something like this right i
actually
like this one on the side it's tapered
to the center as well okay so let's see
what else we can do this is not too bad
um but we can do it better so let me
show you we're gonna go back one step
and one more step okay so let's say this
is how high i wanted the stone to be
ideally you want to make sure to cool it
over here and the tip of a stone it
wanted to have the tip of a stone which
is the cooler to the ring rail in
between 0.5 to 1 millimeter all right so
you don't want this to set it too low
because you might have a chance to break
it
when the jeweler to set it
all right so now what we wanted to do is
we want to draw attention to the middle
so i'm going to make a mark
right at the center right here and
instead of a extruded stray i'm going to
extrude it
to the point
so like this piece is going to extrude
it to this point right there
and you can see that we have this in our
perspective so i want to measure the
angle in between here to here let's
measure it from this line to this line
and that's showing it is 17.3 and it's
really actually close to 18. so if i can
have 18 and 360 degree then i will have
a 20 stone all right so that will work
let's go ahead and draw a line starting
from here and we're just holding the
shift and then we'll draw a straight
line in this line i'm going to rotate it
this one
for
90 degree
and just having that mirror to the other
side
so that is showing it if my setting is
fitting in between here and i will have
a perfect meat for the edges so what we
wanted to do is coming into the
perspective
and let me turn it into the ghost view
and we want to use the command for
orient to point and i'm going to pick up
this one hit enter we don't need a copy
but we do need a scale here on the top
and we do need the 3d scale so that's
snapping into the midpoint to the
midpoint on our hexagon and coming into
the neighbor right here
holding my shift and coming into the
intersection right there as you can see
they scale up a little bit perfectly
well fitting into those two rail there
all right so we're going to do the same
thing coming to the solid extruded
planar curve
and we want to extrude it to the point
so using the common extruded to the
point we're going to select this one
and coming into this point right there
right so now it is perfect fit there
let's give it a try we're gonna pick up
the stone and we're gonna pick up our
setting and coming into the front view
we're gonna use the command called polar
array and we're gonna snapping into the
zero right here and we know we will need
20 stone to be perfectly fit there
and then here we are that we get that
perfect match
on the all edges
all right so let's go back we know that
it's going to work and i'm going to
bring this up a little bit
something like this and we're simply
just going to use a bowline difference
this one out of this one
so then that will cut it open in there
for our stone to sitting and we want to
do the bevel edges there let's say we
want to bevel edges for
pointy six millimeter and we want to
select all the interior right here
and then we can cut it open like that
now we have a stone showing up we want
to work on the prong basically prong is
quite simple
we're gonna coming into the right view
and just draw a straight line straight
down it doesn't have to be too long and
having this one pipe it
so i'm going to pipe it in about
in about this size
and we don't need this like too long
just a little bit over the table
that should work and make sure that it's
not touching the wall
to the edges and then all we need to do
is we need six prong there so let's go
ahead to use polar array command again
and snapping into the center we need six
of them
and we'll get something like that
once you get it we wanted to trim it
down
the inside part so let's go ahead to use
that ring rail and
we simply just want to extrude a command
let's go extrude it straight
make sure both sides equal yes then
we'll have something like this
simply just using
boolean difference
command and having this one and be
trimmed off by this one
what we need to do is having this unit
and we want a
polar array
using the polar array command one more
time snapping into the center remember
that 20 is the magic number so then we
will have this perfectly fit
let's take a look on the render
so this will be our eternity ring for
this hexagon shape of this setting
if you like the way i model i have more
trick and tips on my member only program
so join the membership to watch all the
video thank you for watching
see you next
[Music]
you